an English breakfast made from wool
things are not always what they seem at
the British Museum of food it was
founded by Sam bumpus and Harry par both
from Britain this video installation is
part of the exhibition and was taken
with a pill sized camera normally used
by doctors it shows how food travels
through our bodies the duo Bumpus in
power is known for their unusual food
projects so of course they're museum had
to be something special too I think the
idea of like classical museums which is
the like o series also like temples the
precious objects is becoming more and
more antiquated so here the museum you
don't just come to look at paintings you
don't even come to look at other people
looking at things as well which is what
museums are normally good at you come to
interact with one another that prospect
is especially inviting at the
installation to butterfly effect it
boasts tropical temperatures artificial
sunlight and 400 butterflies flitting
about the room but what our butterfly is
doing in a food museum it's simple they
play a vital role in the pollination of
fruits like bananas a staple food for
many people around the globe
chocoholic should head for choco phonica
where visitors take part in a survey
while eating chocolate they're exposed
to various sounds afterwards they rate
their taste experience the results will
be analyzed at Oxford University which
is studying how noise affects our sense
of taste visitors like the museum's
concept I thought it was great it's not
quite what we expected and but certainly
very enjoyable experience I've never
been to a museum that's so interactive
it is very different to other museums
I've been to I work in a museum in
Ireland and it's much more conventional
museum so it's very nice to see
something pushing the boundaries of
museum work my philosophy is if you give
people a really engaging time most
people are very inquisitive and they'll
start asking questions of course we then
make the message available for people
Sam bumpus and his partner Harry Parr
have been getting their message out
creatively four years in 2007 they
became known as the jelly mongers for
creating architecture out of jelly ever
since the duo has delved into new
culinary terrain they've barbecued over
molten lava and sent coffee beans 37
kilometers into orbit on a helium
balloon
back on earth the beans became space
coffee in 2015 pompous and far served up
a 200 course menu in London the meal
lasted 24 hours when were welcome food
we've always tried to look at the things
that get people really excited they're
normally very few foods which which
university put a smile on people's faces
they tend to be things like coffee
chocolate alcohol and meat and those are
things that when they come to the table
everyone's faces and light up next to
the museum they've opened alcoholic
architecture a walk-in cloud bar that
dispenses breathable cocktails visitors
wander through the alcoholic cloud
wearing plastic ponchos so that at least
their clothes stay dry here you can get
tipsy just from breathing though regular
drinks are on offer to
for the ball hawk helicopters gives you
a drink cases you've never had before
you have the ultimate bragging rights
next time you are any other bar with
your friends the best sort out the food
museum is slated to remain open for
three months but pompous and power are
looking for investors willing to give it
a permanent home then the British Museum
of food would really become the
institution it ought to be